The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi.
Welcome to our lecture
today in Calculus Revisited.
And our topic is going
to be the dot product.
And by way of a preamble,
let me point out
that in our development of
vector spaces in this block, up
until now, we have
deliberately not mentioned
the concept of the dot product,
even though dot product plays
a very prominent role in the
usual vector algebra of two-
and three-dimensional space.
And the reason for
this is that we
wanted to emphasize the
structure of a vector space.
In a manner of speaking,
mathematical structures
are pretty much like
an anatomy-type course,
that one starts with a basic
structure, exploits it,
sees what ramifications it
has, and then gradually adds
on more sophisticated layers
of nerves, nerve centers, skin
grafts, and what have you.
And ultimately, builds
up a superstructure
based on top of an underlying
basic fundamental model.
Now, without going into that
in more detail right now,
let it suffice to say that
I call today's lecture
"Dot Products."
And by way of review, notice
that in the usual two-
and three-dimensional case by
the dot product of two vectors,
we mean a real number.
And if we want to
keep this thing vague
and not indicate the cosine
of the angle between two
vectors, et cetera,
one usually says
that a dot product
is a mapping that
carries ordered pairs of
vectors into the real numbers.
This is the mathematical
way of talking
about what a dot product
is without referring
to angles or lines.
It's a function which maps
ordered pairs of vectors
into real numbers.
In particular, the mapping
must have certain properties
to be called a dot product.
And again, emphasizing
mathematical structure
based on what we already know
is the case from the two-
and three-dimensional
situation, what
properties do we want
the dot product to have?
Well, we would like alpha dot
beta to equal beta dot alpha,
because that's
certainly happened
in the two- and
three-dimensional case.
We would like alpha
dot beta plus gamma
to be alpha dot beta
plus alpha dot gamma.
And if we have a scalar multiple
of alpha dotted with beta,
we would like that to be the
scalar c times the number alpha
dot beta.
Or if we wanted to rewrite
this in vector form,
that the c could also be used
as a scale of multiple of beta.
That c alpha dot theta is
the same as alpha dot c beta.
And where did these
three rules come from?
They came from the properties
that the ordinary dot product
has.
By the way, a dot
product becomes
known as a Euclidean dot
product if, in addition
to the given three
properties, we also
know that the dot product
of a vector and itself,
alpha dot alpha, is a
non-negative real number.
And that in particular,
alpha dot alpha
can equal 0, if and
only if alpha equals 0.
By the way, let me point out
that this fourth condition is
independent of the other three.
That when one studies vector
spaces in more abstract detail,
one usually defines
a dot product
to have just the
first three properties
that we talked about.
And if the fourth property
happens to be present,
then one talks about a
positive-definite dot product.
But not every dot product
has to be positive definite,
except that if we're trying
to imitate the distance
property of real
vector spaces, then we
add the positive-definite
criterion.
And that's explained in more
detail in the study guide
as we do the exercises.
But I did want to
simply point out
that once you know that you
have a positive-definite form,
that alpha dot alpha
is non-negative,
then it makes sense
to abstractly define
the norm or the length of alpha
to be the positive square root
of alpha dot alpha.
You see, this makes
sense, because you
know that alpha dot alpha is
a non-negative real number.
Hence, it has a unique
positive square root.
And this is how we abstract
the usual distance function.
At any rate, to show you how
this works in abstract form,
let's take a
three-dimensional case.
Let's suppose v is a
three-dimensional vector space,
that a particularly-chosen
basis for v is u1, u2, and u3,
and let's suppose that we have
a positive-definite dot product.
And I'll just make this up at
random or semi-random here.
Let's suppose that
I know what the dot
product looks like on all of
the pairs of basis elements.
In other words, I know what u1
dot u1 is, what u2 dot u1 is,
what u3 dot u1 is.
And by the way, by the
property, that u2 dot u1
must equal u1 dot u2, et cetera,
by the commutative property.
Notice that once I
know what u2 dot u1 is,
I also know what u1 dot u2 is.
Once I know what u3
dot u1 is, I know
what u1 dot u3 is, et cetera.
At any rate, there are nine
possible combinations here.
And just try to fix
these in your mind,
because I'll be referring
to these as we go along.
u1 dot u1 is 3.
u1 dot u2 is 4.
u1 dot u3 is 5.
u2 dot u2 is 6.
u2 dot u3 is 7.
And u3 dot u3 is 9.
I just happen to know
that particular amount.
Let's also suppose
that I now want
to find the dot product of
any two vectors in my space,
v. My first claim is-- and
again, this is an overview.
I'll do this in
more abstract detail
in the exercises
in the study guide.
My first point,
though, is that once we
know what the dot product is
for each pair of basis vectors,
we know what the dot product
is for all vectors and pairs
of vectors in the space.
That in particular,
the four rules--
actually, the
three rules that we
have for defining a
dot product tells us
how to compute the dot
product for any two elements.
For example, suppose
I have one 3 tuple,
and just suppose I have two
vectors-- x1u1 plus x2u2
plus x3u3, and y1u1
plus y2u2 plus y3u3.
Let's suppose I want to
find that dot product.
Notice that my distributive
rule for multiplication, coupled
with the commutative properties
and how I can factor out
scale in multiples, tells
me that I multiply these two
trinomials the same way
as I would have had these
been algebraic expressions.
In other words, I dot x1u1
with each of these three terms,
I dot x2u2 with each
of these three terms,
and I dot x3u3 with each
of these three terms.
For example, this will give
me x1y1 times u1 dot u1.
But if you recall, I
said that u1 dot u1 is 3,
so this becomes 3x1y1.
And in a similar way,
when I dot x1u1 with y2u2,
I get x1y2, u1 dot u2.
But I gave the fact
that u1 dot u2 was 4,
so this term becomes 4x1y2.
And in a similar way,
going through this,
I get-- a term will be 5x1y3.
Then, dotting x2u2 with
each of these three terms,
I get three more terms--
4x2y1 plus 6x2y2 plus 7x2y3.
Then I dot x3u3 with each
of these three terms.
Again, just to do
this thing quickly.
x3u3 dotted with y1u1 is
x3y1 times u3 dotted with u1.
And u3 dotted with
u1 was given to be 5.
In fact, it was the same
as u1 dotted with u3
by commutativity, you
see, which was also 5.
At any rate, I get what?
5x3y1 plus 7x3y2 plus 9x3y3.
By the way, at this
particular stage,
I would like to
pause for a moment.
And some of you may have picked
this up better than others,
but at this stage of
the game, maybe you've
already learned how to
look at a system like this
and write it in matrix form.
Now, notice that these are
what we call quadratic forms.
Each term involves an
x multiplied by a y.
I've written this so
that the x's are always
the left side factor and the
y's are always on the right.
Notice that there is a matrix of
coefficients-- namely 3, 4, 5,
4, 6, 7, 5, 7, 9.
And that consequently, I can
write this array of nine terms
simply as the following product.
I write the row
matrix, x1 x2 x3.
Multiply that by
the 3 by 3 matrix--
3 4 5, 4 6 7, 5 7 9, and
multiply that, in turn,
by the column matrix, y1 y2 y3.
As a quick check, notice
that this is a 1 by 3 matrix.
This is 3 by 3.
This is 3 by 1.
And consequently, this will be
a 1 by 1 matrix, or a number.
What number will it be?
It will be this number here.
And notice what I'm saying--
that x1, x2, x3, y1, y2,
y3, are given numbers.
And consequently, the
dot product in question
is determined as soon as I
know these coefficients, which
happen to be the dot products
of the basis elements with one
another.
So this shows two things.
One, how we write
this in matrix form.
And two, how the dot product
of each two vectors in v
is determined by
just knowing what
happens to the pairs of basis
vectors when we dot them.
And this gives us
still another way
of seeing how matrices are
used as a coding system.
In other words,
every symmetric--
remember what symmetric means?
You get the same matrix when you
interchange rows and columns.
Every symmetric n by n
matrix codes a dot product.
And conversely,
every dot product
is coded by a symmetric
n by n matrix.
You see, what does
this matrix tell me?
This is the entry in the i--
the entry in the
i-th row, j-th column
is what happens when u sub
i is dotted with u sub j.
Without meaning to
belabor this point,
let us notice that
the array here--
3 4 5, 4 6 7, 5 7 9-- is
precisely the array that we had
over here--
3 4 5, 4 6 7, 5 7 9.
This is what we
mean when we talk
about the matrix
of the dot product.
It's the array of how the basis
vectors look when you dot them
with one another.
By the way, as another
aside, we agreed
that when a vector
with itself, that
can be identified in a way
with the length of the vector.
In particular, going
back to this example
here, if the x's and the
y's are chosen to be equal--
if I let x1 equal y1, x2
equal y2, and x3 equals y3,
this problem here
reduces to this problem.
Which in turn, just
combining what I had above--
in other words, with the
x's and the y's equal--
gives me that to find the square
of the length of a vector,
I have to solve this
particular algebraic equation.
And this algebraic equation
is called a quadratic form.
You see, notice that each of
the variables, x1, x2, x3,
appears in each term here
as a second-degree variable.
See, here's an x1 squared.
Here's x1 times x2.
You see two factors--
x1 times x3.
And what I'm driving
at, again, is aside
from any other
connections, notice
that to solve for the length
of a particular vector, one
has to wind up solving what
we call quadratic forms.
And these, for two
and three dimensions,
can be identified with
certain curves in two-
or three-dimensional space.
But I don't want to belabor that
point too much here, either.
I just want you
to get a buckshot
overview of how one works
abstractly with the dot product
idea.
By the way, some
new terminology.
If v is an n dimensional vector
space with basis u1 up to u n,
we call the basis u1 up
to u n an orthogonal basis
relative to a given
dot product if the dot
product of any two different
members of the basis is 0.
In other words, if
u sub i dot u sub
j is 0 for all i
unequal to j, we
call this an orthogonal
basis, for the usual reason
of what orthogonal means.
When the dot product
of two arrows was zero,
we said the arrows were
perpendicular, et cetera.
This is just a
carryover from that.
In particular, if in
addition, the dot product
of any vector with
itself happens to be 1,
then the basis is called
an orthonormal basis.
And this whole idea is modeled
after the usual example
that in three-dimensional
space, i
j k forms an orthonormal basis,
relative to the usual dot
product.
In other words, i dot j, i
dot k, and j dot k are all 0.
But i dot i, j dot j,
and k dot k are all 1.
Now, the interesting point
is that in most textbooks,
one always defines the dot
product in much the same way
as we do i, j, and k.
One always assumes
that somehow or other,
we have an orthonormal basis.
Now, obviously in
the example I'm
motivating today's
lecture on, we
don't have an orthonormal basis.
Remember, we had something
like u1 dot u2 was 4.
Well, see, to be orthonormal,
u1 dot u2, first of all,
would have to be 0, and u1
dot u1 would have to be 1.
But in our example,
u1 dot u1 is 3.
So the question that
comes up is, do we always
have an orthonormal basis?
And the answer is yes.
And in fact, if you like big
words, the process by which we
construct an orthonormal basis--
in fact, the process is
easier than the name.
The name is called the
Gram-Schmidt orthogonalization
process.
And geometrically, what
the method boils down to
is that if I'm given two
non-parallel vectors,
u1 and u2, to find the
space spanned by u1 and u2,
I can replace u2 by the
component of u2, which
is perpendicular to u1.
Let's call that
component u2 star.
What I'm saying is
that u1 and u2 star
span the same
space as u1 and u2.
But obviously,
geometrically, it's
easy to see that u1 and
u2 star are orthogonal.
Now, the question
is, how could we
get the same result without
having to rely on geometry?
And the answer is,
we say, look it.
We know already in our
course that in terms
of spanning vectors,
if you replace
a vector by itself plus or minus
a scalar multiple of another,
you don't change
the space spanned
by the given set of vectors.
So why not write u2 star to be
u2 minus some suitable multiple
of u1?
See, u2 minus xu1,
where we'll try
to determine x in such a way
that u2 star, dotted with u1,
will be 0.
You see, what we're
going to try to do
is replace u2 by an
equivalent vector,
meaning that u1 and u2 star
will span the same space
as u1 and u2, but with
the additional property
that u1 and u2 star
will be orthogonal.
Whereas, u1 and u2 might
not have been orthogonal.
And now you see, we can
proceed axiomatically.
Namely, we say, OK.
What we want to look
at is u2 star dot u1.
So let's start both sides
of this equation with u1.
You see, the left-hand side
will become u2 star dot u1.
The right-hand side becomes u2
minus xu1, 1 dotted with u1.
But by our
distributive property,
this is the same as u2
dot u1 minus xu1 dot u1.
Now, we didn't want x
to be any old number.
We wanted x to be that
number, if one exists,
that makes u2 star
dot u1 equal to 0.
Remember, u2 dot u1 and
u1 dot u1 are numbers.
Consequently, I treat this as
an ordinary algebraic equation.
Namely, this is a number.
This is a number.
I equate this to
0 and solve for x.
In other words, x is u2 dot
u1 divided by u1 dot u1.
And by the way, just as an
aside, many mathematicians,
as an abbreviation
when they want
to write the dot product
of a vector and itself,
they write it as the
square of the given vector.
Obviously, this cannot mean
the usual squaring operation,
because we don't multiply
vectors by themselves.
This obviously refers
to the dot product.
And I mention this
in passing, simply
so that if you see
this in the literature,
you will not be confused by it.
I prefer to write u1 dot
u1 rather than u1 squared,
but we'd like you to see
this notation anyway.
At any rate, now
knowing what x is,
I replace x here
into this equation,
and I wind up with
that u2 star is
u2 minus u2 dot u1 over
u1 dot u1 times u1.
And if you want to check
this thing geometrically,
the u2 star that I've
computed this way
is precisely the u2 star
that I get geometrically.
The beauty of this
technique is that it did not
require geometry.
And consequently,
structurally, I
should be able to use
this in higher dimensions.
And that's exactly what the
Gram-Schmidt orthogonalization
process is.
What you do is is you
start with a basis.
You take the first
vector in that basis
and dot it with
the second vector.
If that dot product is
0, those two vectors
are both eligible to be
part of an orthogonal basis.
Now, if that dot
product isn't 0,
you use the Gram-Schmidt
orthogonalization process
to replace the second
vector, u2, by u2 star,
where u1 dot u2 star is 0.
Now you take that new basis,
which spans the same space
as the original u1 and
u2, and compare that
or take that in
connection with u3
and see if those three vectors
form an orthogonal basis--
or orthogonal, meaning their dot
product of different ones is 0.
And if it is, fine.
And if it isn't, you
just inductively keep
using the Gram-Schmidt
orthogonalization process.
Now, to show you what this
means in a specific case,
let's suppose I have
the following situation.
Let's suppose I have a
four-dimensional vector
space for which a basis
is u1, u2, u3, and u4.
Suppose I also know that u1, u2,
and u3 form an orthogonal set.
That means I know that
u1 dot u2, u1 dot u3,
and u2 dot u3 are all 0.
But I don't know that
u4 dot u1, u4 dot u2,
u4 dot u3 are 0 or
anything like this.
And the question
that comes up now
is, I would like to replace u4
by an equivalent vector, which
I'll call u sub 4 star, such
that u1, u2, u3, and u sub
4 star span the
same space, v. But
that now with u4
replaced by u4 star,
this becomes an
orthogonal basis.
Well, the way I proceed
is I use the fact
that whenever I replace a
vector by itself, plus or minus
a linear combination
of the other vectors,
I don't change the space
spanned by the vectors.
So what I say is,
let u4 star be u4
minus x1u1 minus
x2u2 minus x3u3.
You see, I'm modeling
this after what I did
in the two-dimensional case.
What I want to do is
determine x1, x2, and x3
such that u4 star dot
u1, u4 star dot u2,
and u4 star dot
u3 will all be 0.
And the trick is simply this.
Let me focus my attention on
one of these coefficients,
because the technique is
the same for all the others.
Let's suppose I want
to find out what x3 is.
The trick is, I dot both sides
of this equation with u3.
Now, why do I do that?
Remember, u1, u2, and u3
are an orthogonal set.
Consequently, when I dot
u1 with u3 and u2 with u3,
those terms will be 0,
and they will drop out.
In other words, dotting both
sides of this equation with u3
and using the fact that the
dot product is distributive,
I get u4 star dot
u3 is u4 dot u3
minus x1u1 dot u3 minus x2u2
dot u3 minus x3u3 dot u3.
And the key point is that by
orthogonality, these two things
here are 0.
Consequently, u4 star dot u3
is u4 dot u3 minus x3u3 dot u3.
Remember, these are numbers.
I would like u4 star dot u3 to
be 0, so all I have to do now
is solve this algebraic
equation for x3.
And notice that x3
algebraically simply turns out
to be u4 dot u3 over u3 dot u3.
Again, the only thing I
have to be careful about
is that the
denominator not be 0.
And notice that by
positive definiteness,
u3 dot u3 can only equal
0 if u3 is the 0 vector.
But if u3 had been the 0 vector,
it couldn't be part of a basis.
So you get the idea
of how this works.
This is the same Gram-Schmidt
orthogonalization process
that we used in two dimensions.
Because once we know that
all the vectors up to u sub 4
are orthogonal, whenever
we dot one of them
with the other
three, we essentially
reduce this to a
two-dimensional problem,
because all the other
dot products drop out.
In a similar way,
you see, I could
have found x sub 2 and x sub
1, leaving the details to you.
The easiest way to
remember this is
every place I see a
subscript 3 over here,
let me replace it by a 2.
And then every place I see the
3, let me replace it by a 1.
And what I get is
that u4 star is u4.
And then I subtract off
these scalar multiples.
What scalar multiples are they?
Notice that it's what?
The coefficient of u1 is
u4 dot u1 over u1 dot u1.
The coefficient of u2 has as
its denominator u2 dot u2.
The numerator is
u4 dotted with u2.
In other words, in a sense,
it's like the projection of u4
onto u2.
And the coefficient of u3 has
as its denominator u3 dot u3,
and its denominator
is u4 dot u3.
Now, to show you how
this works, let's
come back to our
original problem, which
I've reproduced over here.
Remember what we had.
We had that u1 dot u1
is 3, u1 dot u2 is 4,
u1 dot u3 is 5, et cetera.
I'll refer to this as I need it.
Let me show you how the
Gram-Schmidt process allows
me to find, from this,
an orthogonal basis.
The first thing is
that obviously, u1
is not the 0 vector, because
if it were the 0 vector,
u1 dot u1 would be 0, not 3.
So the first vector in
my orthogonal basis,
which I'll call u1
star, can be u1 itself.
How do I find the second vector?
According to the Gram-Schmidt
orthogonalization process,
I replace u2 by u2
minus a suitable scalar
multiple of u1 star.
And what scalar
multiple is that?
The denominator will
be u1 star dot u1 star,
and the numerator will
be u2 dot u1 star.
Well, remember, u1
star is equal to u1.
So right from this array
here, what do I have?
u2 dot u1 star is u2 dot u1.
u2 dot u1 is 4.
u1 star dot u1
star is u1 dot u1.
u1 dot u1 is 3.
So this is simply what?
Minus 4 over 3 times u1.
In other words, u2 star
is simply u2 minus 4/3 u1.
And by the way, as a check,
what was this supposed to do?
If I replaced u2 by u2
star, these two vectors
here should now be orthogonal.
Are they?
Let's start them.
If I dot these two, I get what?
u1 dot u2 minus 4/3 u1 dot u1.
Notice that u1 dot u2 is 4.
u1 dot u1 is 3.
So coming down here
as a check, u1 star
dot u2 star is u1 minus u2,
which is 4, minus 4/3 u1 dot
u1, which is 3.
The 3's cancel.
4 minus 4 is 0.
This checks out fine.
How do I find u3 star?
Well, I subtract from u3
suitable scalar multiples
of u1 star and u2 star.
You see what I've done.
I orthogonalized one
vector at a time.
See, first I got u2 star.
Now I know that u1
star and u2 star
are orthogonal, using
u1 star and u2 star,
the multiples that I
subtract from u3 are what?
For u1 star, my denominator
is u1 star dot u1 star,
and my numerator
is u3 dot u1 star.
And for u2 star, my denominator
is u2 star dot u2 star,
and my numerator
is u3 dot u2 star.
And now how do I evaluate
what this thing really means?
Well, first of all, I know
what u3 dot u1 star is.
That's just u3 dot u1,
which happens to be 5.
And I also know what
u1 star dot u1 star is.
That's u1 dot u1, which is 3.
I now have to compute what?
u3 dot u2 star, and I have
to compute u2 dot u2 star.
Keep in mind that I've already
computed that u2 star is
u2 minus 4/3 u1.
Consequently, u3 dot u2 star
is u3 dot u2 minus 4/3 u1.
And now you see the mechanical
algebra takes over again.
I know what my axioms
for dot products are.
This gives me u3 dot
u2, minus 4/3 u3 dot u1.
I'm given that u3 dot u2 is 7.
I'm given that u3 dot u1 is 5.
So u3 dot u2 star
is 7 minus 4/3 of 5.
That's 1/3-- 21 minus
20 over 3, which is 1/3.
So let's see what I know now.
I know now how to
handle this numerator.
u3 dot u2 star is 1/3.
How do I handle u2
star dot u2 star?
u2 star is u2 minus 4/3 u1.
So to find u2 star dot u2 star,
I have to dot u2 minus 4/3 u1
with itself.
If I do that-- and
again, notice how
these rules work the same
way as for ordinary algebra.
I get u2 dot u2 minus 8/3 u1
dot u2 plus 16/9 u1 dot u1.
Well, I know that
u2 dot u2 is 6.
That was given.
I know that u2 dot u2
is 6, u1 dot u2 is 4,
and u1 dot u1 is 3.
So evaluating this, I
wind up with the fact
that u2 star dot u2 star
is 6 minus 16/3, or 2/3.
Consequently, going back here,
you see my numerator is 1/3.
My denominator is 2/3,
so the fraction is 1/2.
In other words,
substituting into here,
I get that u3 star
is u3 minus 5/3
u1 minus 1/2 u2 minus 4/3 u1.
And retabulating my
results to write them
in the usual order of u1,
u2, and u3 components,
notice that u1 star is u1.
u2 star is minus 4/3 u1 plus u2.
u3 star is minus u1
minus 1/2 u2 plus u3.
Now, what property does
this set of vectors have?
First of all, my claim is
that they're orthogonal.
And secondly, they span the
same space as u1, u2, and u3.
And it's clear why they span the
Namely, they're essentially
suitable scalar multiples
of u1, u2--
linear combinations of scalar
multiples of u1, u2, and u3.
As a quick check--
and I'll leave
some of the other
details to you.
Let's actually check that u1
star dot u3 star is really 0.
If I dot u1 star with u3
star, look at what I get.
I get minus u1 dot u1 minus
1/2 u1 dot u2 plus u1 dot u3.
u1 dot u1 is 3.
u1 dot u2 is 4.
So this is minus
3 minus 1/2 of 4.
That's minus 2.
u1 dot u3 is 5, minus
3 minus 2 plus 5 is 0.
A similar check will show
that u2 star dot u3 star is 0.
We should also check to see
what the lengths of u1 star,
u2 star, and u3 star are.
In other words, u1 star
dot u1 star is what?
That's u1 dot u1, which is 3.
u2 star dot u2 star--
well, we just found
that over here.
That's 2/3.
u3 star dot u3 star--
well, u3 star was minus
u1 minus 1/2 u2 plus u3.
Dotting that with
itself-- and notice
I used the square notation
here to save space
and not have this run too long.
But dotting this,
the same as I would
the square of any
trinomial, I get what?
u1 dot u1 plus 1/4 u2 dot u2
plus u3 dot u3 plus u1 dot u2
minus twice u1 dot
u3 minus u2 dot u3.
Putting in the
values for u1 dot u1,
for u2 dot u2, u3 dot u3, u1 dot
u2, u1 dot u3, and u2 dot u3--
putting in these values,
I find that u3 star
dot u3 star is 1/2.
So I have an orthogonal basis.
It's not orthonormal,
but notice that it's
easy to fix up the normality
part, because all I have to do
is divide each of these
vectors by the square root
of this number, and that
will make the dot product 1.
For example, if I were
to replace u1 star
by u1 star over the
square root of 3,
then when I dotted
these two vectors,
I would have 3 divided
by the square root
of 3 times the square
root of 3, which is 3.
And 3 over 3 is 1.
So getting the lengths
to be one is quite easy.
The hard part is this
Gram-Schmidt orthogonalization
process to orthogonalize
what's going on.
Now, this may seem
rather complicated,
but it's really one long
piece of computation.
We'll do this more
slowly in the exercises.
But the whole idea is what?
I successively use the
Gram-Schmidt orthogonalization
process to replace
each vector by
a suitable linear combination
of itself and the preceding ones
to make sure that the
new replacement is
orthogonal to the
remaining ones,
and that doesn't change the
space that I already have.
By the way, if you
want to see what
this means in terms of
matrix multiplication,
notice that we saw earlier that
to dot a vector with itself,
you write the vector
as a row vector,
then write down the matrix
of coefficients for the basis
elements, then write down that
same vector as a column vector.
The fact that u1 star is
u1 plus 0 u2 plus 0 u3
means that as a 3 tuple,
it would be 1 0 0.
It's transpose would be 1
0 0-- the column vector.
And so when we take
this vector and dot it
with this vector, that
should be the entry,
u1 dot u1, in this
particular matrix here.
If we take this times
this, this should
be u1 star dotted with u2 star.
And since u1 star and
u2 star are orthogonal,
that had better
come out to be 0.
And going on in this
way, what I claim
is, if you now replace u1
star, u2 star, and u3 star
by what 3 tuples they are,
then also replace them
as column vectors here, you will
get a new 3 by 3 matrix which
will be diagonal.
In other words, if we change
our basis from u1, u2, and u3--
if we change that basis to
u1 star, u2 star, u3 star,
notice that the new matrix that
we get is a diagonal matrix.
It's our way of saying that when
you dot two different vectors,
the dot product is 0.
The diagonal elements
tell you what
u1 star dot u1 star are--
u2 star dot u2 star,
u3 star dot u3 star.
You see, by using the
diagonal matrix over here,
this is a much
simpler model to use.
u1 star, u2 star, u3 star
is a much nicer basis
to use than u1,
u2, and u3 in order
to determine what
dot products are.
I'll emphasize that
in more detail later.
Let me make one remark before I
get to our concluding remarks.
And that is, have you begun to
notice how complicated matrices
are from the point
of view that they
are such a wonderful coding
device that we use them
to code many different things?
For example, we
have used matrices
to code a linear transformation
relative to various bases.
We're now using matrices to
code the same dot product
relative to different bases.
We have used matrices to code
equivalent row-reduced bases
as bases for the
same vector space.
That at the end of this
unit, what I will do
is try to give you a
summary in the study
guide of the different
kinds of matrix equivalents
and where they're used.
Because after a
while, you tend to get
mixed up if we don't see these
pieces one bit at a time.
But to help you see what
all this problem means,
I have cheated--
that the place I got the
data from for the u1, u2,
and u3 in this
problem was that I
thought of the following
three vectors--
i plus j plus k, 2i plus j
plus k, 2i plus j plus 2k--
and used this to make up the
data for u1, u2, and u3 that
was in this exercise.
What you may find
informative, and what
I will do as a
learning exercise,
is have you go through
the same exercise
that we have just
done as today's lesson
and have you verify that this
checks out with the equivalent
geometric
construction-- that one
of the exercises in
the homework will
be to show what the Gram-Schmidt
orthogonalization process means
geometrically for
these three vectors.
By the way, rather than to
belabor that point for now,
let me make one other aside.
And that is, I had
mentioned before that
to find the dot
product of two vectors,
it may be more
advantageous to use
one basis rather than another.
Remember, when we wanted to
dot a vector with itself,
using u1, u2, and u3
as a basis, remember
we got six different terms?
We had an x1 squared, x2
squared, x3 squared, an x1x2,
x1x3, and x2x3 term.
Notice that when you
pick an orthogonal basis,
you only get three terms.
Because once the basis is
orthogonal, all you have to do
is dot corresponding entries.
Because you see,
if I dot u1 star
with a term involving
u2 star or u3 star,
that will be 0 by orthogonality.
If I didn't have an
orthogonal basis,
I couldn't neglect those terms.
So for example, to dot
a vector with itself
in this particular example,
using u1 star, u2 star,
and u3 star as a basis, notice
that what I wind up with
is what?
x1 times x1. x1
squared times u1 star
dot u1 star, which
is 3, et cetera.
Meaning 3x1 squared plus
2/3 x2 squared plus 1/2 x3
squared, which is the square
of the length of the vector
that I'm looking for.
If I put everything over
a common denominator,
I get a very nice equation
for an ellipsoid over here.
You see a very nice equation
with no mixed terms--
just perfect squares
appearing over here.
The mixed terms drop out,
and that's one reason
why we like orthogonal bases.
Still another reason that
we like orthogonal bases--
and I'll conclude
with this example--
is that if we know that
the vectors u1 up to u n
are orthonormal, say, and
that x1u1 plus et cetera x n u
n is 0, then we automatically
know that the u's are--
that x1 up to x n are 0--
that these are
linearly independent.
And the proof is quite simple.
Namely, all we do is we dot
both sides of this equation
with, for example, u sub 1.
We could've used any one
of the u's that we wanted,
but using u sub
1, we dot u sub 1
with both sides
of this equation.
Notice that this term
gives me x1u1 dot u1.
The next terms are what?
u1 dot u2 up to u1 dot u n.
By the property of
being orthogonal,
all of these products are 0.
Consequently, this scalar
times x1 must be 0.
Consequently, x1
itself must be 0.
I've deliberately
gone very rapidly here
to give you an
overview, and to also
have you see, as
I'm talking, what
these computations look like.
I think by hearing this, as
complicated as it may sound,
I think when you now read the
solutions to the exercises,
you will have a better
feeling for what's going on.
And as I say, in
the exercises, I
will develop these
topics much more slowly,
and you can read these
solutions as we go along.
At any rate, this presents
our overview of dot products.
And so until next
time, then, goodbye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.